>> THREATEN TO PULL OUT OF THE
SUMMIT WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DUE TO THE ON GOING MILITARY
EXERCISES.
THAT HE KNEW ABOUT WITH SOUTH
KOREA AND THE U.S.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE A MASSIVE
IMPROVEMENT IN GAIN DMT KOREAN
PENINSULA AND SOME WOULD ARGUE
HIS TOUGH TALK AND MILITARY
PRESENCE AND SANCTIONS ALL
WORKED.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> NORTH KOREA MUST NOT MAKE
MORE THREATS TO THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY WILL MESS WITH FIRE AND
FURY LIKE THE WORLD HAS NEVER
SEEN.
>> THE UNITED STATES HAS GREAT
STRENGTHS AND PATIENCE.
IF IT IS FORCED DEFEND ITSELF
FOR AL ICE.
WE WILL HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
TOTALLY DESTROY NORTH KOREA.
ROCKET MAN IS ON A SUED MISSION
FROM HIMSELF.
AND FOR HIS REGIME.
>> THIS SHOULD NOT BE HANDLED
NOW.
BUT I WILL HANDLE IT BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO HANDLE IT.
>> LITTLE ROCKET MAN -- WE WILL
DO IT BECAUSE WE REALLY HAVE NO
CHOICE
>> WHAT IS AMAZING THE
PRESIDENT'S TOUGH RHETORIC PROVE
WHAT IS REAGAN SPOKE ABOUT IN
THE 80s EVIL THE SOVIET UNION
AND PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH TRUST
BY VERIFY.
>> WELL IS ONE SIGN THE SOVIETS
MAKE THAT IS UNMISTAKABLE.
THAT WOULD VETERANS DRAMATICALLY
THE CAUSE OF FREEDOM AND PEACE.
GENERAL SECRETARY GOSH CHAFF, IF
YOU SEEK PEACE AND PROSPERITY,
IF YOU SEEK LIBERALIZATION.
COME HERE TO THIS GATE, OPEN
THIS GATE.
>> MR. GAUCHE
>> MR. GAUCH
>> MR. GORCH
>> MR. GORBA
>> MR. GORBACH
>> MR. GORBACHEV
>> MR. GORBACHEV T
>> MR. GORBACHEV TAK
>> MR. GORBACHEV TAKE
>> MR. GORBACHEV TAKE D
>> MR. GORBACHEV TAKE DOW
>> MR. GORBACHEV TAKE DOWN
>> MR. GORBACHEV TAKE DOWN T
>> MR. GORBACHEV TAKE DOWN THI
>> MR. GORBACHEV TAKE DOWN THIS
WALL
>> HIS AIDS DID NOT WANT HIM TO
SAY THOSE WORDS.
RAYING
RAYIN
REAIN
REAGA
REAGAN
REAGAN'S TRUST BUT VERIFY
>> WE HAVE LISTENED TO THE
WISDOM OF AN OLD RUSSIAN MACKIM.
>> I'M SURE YOU ARE FAMILIAR
WITH IT.
MR. GENERAL SECOND MY
PRONUNCIATION MAY GIVE YOU
DIFFICULT
DIFFICUL
DIFFICULTY THE MACKUM IS --
TRUST BUT VERIFY.
[LAUGHTER].
>> GAUCHE
>> GAUCH
>> GORCH
>> GORBA
>> GORBACH
>> GORBACHEV
>> GORBACHEV I
>> GORBACHEV IS
>> GORBACHEV IS L
>> GORBACHEV IS LAU
>> GORBACHEV IS LAUGH
>> GORBACHEV IS LAUGH W
>> GORBACHEV IS LAUGH WIL
>> GORBACHEV IS LAUGH WILLI
>> GORBACHEV IS LAUGH WILLING
IS A BOOK OUT CALLED THREE DAY
IN MOSCOW.
REAGAN IN THE FALL OF THE SOVIET
EMPIRATE ANCHOR.
OUR FRIEND.
GOOD TO SEE WE ARE NOT FRIENDS
EVERY NEWSPAPER LOCAL,
INTERNATIONAL AND NATIONAL.
THEY HAVE A SPORT'S SECTION.
IF I WILL PAGE?
YOU OTHER NEWS PAGE
>> THIS IS A IS IRRELEVANT VANLT
TO IRAN AND NORTH KOREA AND EVEN
THE OPENING OF THE EMBASSY IN
JERUSALEM.
REMEMBER THOSE TIME WHEN IS
REAGAN WAS SPEAKING OUT ABOUT
THE E VIL EMPIRE AND THE SHEEP
OF HISTORY COMMUNISM WOULD BE
JOKES AT TIMES GETTING CAUGHT
LIKE THE BOMB WILL START
TOMORROW.
HEADS WERE EXPLODING IN
WASHINGTON AT THE TEAM.
>> SOUND FAMILIAR?
>> HEADS ARE EXPLODING IN
WASHINGTON IF JOHN 12TH HOLD AND
IT IS SUMMIT HAPPENS.
JUNE 12 IS HISTORIC.
JUNE 12, 1987 THE GATE SPEECH.
TAKE DOWN THIS WALL MR.
GORBACHEV.
THAT CHANGED THAT AND THE
COLLECTION OF THEM.
CHANGED OUR HISTORY.
IT IS POSSIBLE.
>> YOU KNOW LOOK AT WHAT
ALREADY THE PRESIDENT WITHOUT
PLAYING IN CASH LIKE OBAMA DID
OR CLINTON WITH THE ENERGY AID
TO KIM JONG-UN'S FATHER THIS
PRESIDENT TALKED TOUGH.
PUT A MILITARY PRESENCE AND
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CHINESE
PRESIDENT AND SANCTIONS IN
PLACE.
DIDN'T THAT REALLY ALL
CREDIBILITY TO KIM JONG-UN'S
DECISION HERE?
>> I WOULD THINK SO.
NOW THE CAVEAT IS THE NORTH
KOREANS DON'T LIVE UP TO THEIR
PROMISES THE PRESIDENT SAID HE
WILL SITS AT TABLE AND WALK AWAY
IF THE DEAL IS NOT RIGHT.
THE SIMILARITIES ARE REALLY
STARK.
PERSONALITIES ARE DIFFERENT.
I DON'T THINK REAGAN WOULD LOVE
TWITTER WHO KNOWS.
MAY BE HE WOULD.
BUT HE DID SAY THOSE BOLD THINGS
THAT CHANGED THE PAIR DIME
AND -- MAY BE IT SHOULD BE NOW.
>> THE THING IS THEY SAID HE
WAS A CALIFORNIA COWBOY AND HE
WOULD START WORLD WAR THREE AND
SAID WOULD RESULT IN THE
COLLAPSE OF THE ECONOMY.
21 MILLION JOB REMEMBER CREATE
DOUBLE REVENUES AND THE LONGEST
PERIOD OF PEACETIME IN HISTORY.
I KNOW I'M BRAG A BIT IN
OPINION.
>> I DOT LAST WORD OF THIS BOOK
I DRAW.
GET TO THAT PAGE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE WORDINGS OF
BIG SPEECHES OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SPEECH POLAND.
THE UNITED NATION'S SPEECH.
STATE UNION SPEECH.
THEY HAVE PRAISE
THEY HAVE PRAIS
THEY HAVE PHRIS
THEY HAVE PHRAS
THEY HAVE PHRASES
THEY HAVE PHRASES A
THEY HAVE PHRASES AND
TERMINOLOGY YOU COULD HEAR
REAGAN DELIVERING.
NOW I'M NOT SAYING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PRESIDENT
REAGAN.
PRESIDENT REAGAN.
>> VERY DIFFERENT BUT THEY HAVE
SIMILAR MOMENTS AND CHALLENGES
THEY ARE FACING.
>> PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH.
TRUST BUT VERIFY.
TAX CUTS NOW THE TRUMP TAX CUTS.
ORIGINALISTS ON THE SUPREME
COURT.
SECURING THE BORDER.
I -- I DON'T BELIEVE THIS
PRESIDENT IS A NATIONALIST
POPULIST.
I BELIEVE HE IS A REAGAN
CONFERRINGIVE THE THINGS I
MENTIONED ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
ARE ALL THINGS THAT REAGAN
BELIEVED IN.
YOU ARE NOT WRONGFUL I THINK THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THIS PRESIDENT
HAS THE ABILITY TO REACH OUT TO
DEMOCRATS AND MAKE DEALS THAT
REAGAN WOULD WITH TIP OSHG NEIL
AND OTHERS.
>> BOOK IS FASCINATING I'M
SAYING THIS AS A FRIEND.
IT IS AN AMAZING READ IT IS
RELEVANT FROM TODAY'S HEAD
LINES.
GREAT BOOK.
HOW MUCH CRAP DO YOU TAKE FOR ME
BEING OPINIONATED?
>> ON A SCALE OF ONE TO 10?
A GOOD, SIX.
IT WILL EVERYBODY YOUR NEWS I'M
OPINION AND EVERY PAPER IS NEWS,